- - Notre panel ce soir : four-
popoint bonsoir à vous... commes
avavec cette petite surprise. Le
miministre de la santé Christian
DuDubé qui y est allé d'une
atattaque frontale envers les
sysyndicats entre autres des
ininfirmières en disant : les
prprimes, ce n'est pas pour le
dédélégué syndical.
LeLes infirmières n'étaient pas
cocontentes. Comment vous
l'l'expliquez cette attaque?
- - C'est sûr contre le
gogouvernement et les syndicats,
cece faire sur faire. Les
sysyndicats en général depuis 50
anans ont l'habitude de jouer
etet le gouvernement veut faire
leles choses différemment et vet
rerenforcer différents posts
d'd'emploi. Et les attaques de
frfront, les isolants disant : s
ininfirmières sont toujours nos
ananges gardiens mais nos
sysyndicats commencent à étirere
lala CPAM Alfort. Ceux qui ont e
mamauvais rôle ce soir alors
ququ'elle se défende en disant :
cece n'était pas tout à fait ça
ququi était discuté à la table.
- - Michel là-dessus?
- - Depuis le début de la
papandémie, on sent que
l'l'exaspération de M. Legault
momonte d'un mois à l'autre. Ily
a a eu la question des offres
didifférenciées dans le secteur
pupublic qui l'empêchait d'offrr
dedes augmentations plus
imimportantes à des acteurs clés
dudurant la pandémie. Le préposé
auaux bénéficiaires, les
ininfirmières maintenant. Disons
quque Monsieur Legault au départ
elelle n'est pas un grand
sysyndicaliste. Ce qui s'est paé
auau cours des derniers mois, je
pepense, là exaspéré et il faut
didire que le plan de rétentionu
dede rappel de Jean, infirmière
susurtout dans le réseau de la
sasanté donne déjà pas des bons
rérésultats. Avoir un obstacle e
plplus, ça lui sert à la fois ps
dedes prétextes, mais il a troué
unun bon bogue émissaire.
LaLa vérité est que son plan à e
lala difficulté à fonctionner
mamalgré ça.
- - Notre collègue Véronique
prprince disait on n'en a recrué
86864 et on n'en cherche 5000.
- - On est loin du compte.
- - J'enchaîne avec un autre
susujet. Je vais vous lancer là-
dedessus Christian. Partiellemet
MaMarie-Victorin. Il y a un pose
ququi se libère puisque Catherie
FoFournier est devenue mairessee
LoLongueuil. Ça serait une
ococcasion pour le chef du parti
ququébécois Paul St-Pierre
PlPlamondon d'attenter à tout le
momoins de se faire élire. On st
quque c'est un château fort
pépéquiste. Il a été étonnant
auaujourd'hui, il dit : j'ai une
ststratégie mais je ne veux pas
vovous en parler tout de suite.n
vava écouter un petit extrait
susuivi d'une réaction de Françs
LeLegault.
PAPAUL ST-PIERRE PLAMONDON,
chchef, Parti québécois
- - On a une stratégie
dadans Marie-Victorin.
- - (journaliste):
EÉlaborez laquelle.
- - Ils m'ont dit de pas
vovous le dire si vous
meme posiez la question!
- - J'ai bien noté l'hésitation
dede PSPP. J'aimerais d'abord
sasavoir si le chef du Parti
ququébécois veut se présenter
dadans Marie-Victorin avant
dede prendre une décision
sisi on va ou non présenter
unun candidat dans Marie-Victor.
- - qu'est-ce que vous comprenez
dede la stratégie de Paul Saint-
PiPierre Plamondon qu'il ne veut
papas nous dire s'il va se
prprésenter ou pas?
- - Je pense que sa décision n't
papas prise encore. Plusieurs
didisent qu'il n'a pas le choixe
sese présenter. Je ne suis pas
d'd'accord. C'est un gros test e
leleadership. S'il est gentil, l
vava aller au combat. Il n'a pas
grgrand-chose à gagner là-dedan.
IlIl a énormément à perdre.
PoPourquoi irait-elle à ce comb?
GaGabriel Nadeau Dubois n'a pas
fafaire de cadeaux à Paul Saint-
PiPierre Plamondon. Il n'a pas
rerespececté la tradition de nes
prprésenter de candidats contre
MoMonsieur Paul Saint-Pierre
PlPlamonondon. S'il est vraiment
fofort, il n'ira pas, parce que
popour lui l'enjeu est l'électin
gégénérale, ce n'est pas cette
élélection partielle. Je suis
coconvaincue que beaucoup de
cocommentateur monde qu'il n'a s
lele choix. Il a le choix. Il
n'n'est pas obligé. Pourquoi il
irirait là? Et s'il n'y va pas,i
lele PQ gagnait, ce serait bon.i
lele PQ perd, tant mieux.
- - Vous en pensez quoi Michel
DaDavid?
- - Il peut choisir le moindre
mamal. Je pense que ce défilé, à
teterme, ça causerait moins de
dodommages que de se faire batt.
DaDans Marie-Victorin, les chans
sosont que Monsieur Saint-Pierre
PlPlamondon se fasse battre.
MaMadame Fournier avait gagné la
cicirconscription avec plus de 0
vovoix. C'était déjà beaucoup
momoins que les 3700 que Bernard
DrDrainville avait gagnés en 204
dedepuis sept ans, le PQ a
cocontinué à perdre des plumes t
lala CAQ à monter. Ses chances e
vivictoire sont minces. Je pense
quque ce qui peut... ce que doit
considérer Monsieur Paul Saint-
PiPierre Plamondon, c'est la dae
àà laquelle Monsieur Legault va
dédéclencher. S'il déclenchait
tatard, au bout de l'échéance de
sisix mois, ça serait plus facie
popour Monsieur Saint-Pierre
PlPlamondon de dire : il reste
jujuste deux ou trois semaines e
cecession, ça ne vaut pas la
pepeine, je vais attendre la
gégénérale. S'il déclenche au tt
dédébut de la nouvelle année, ça
vava devenir plus gênant. Il pat
dadans les deux cas, mais je pee
ququ'il perdrait moins à ne pasy
alaller.
- - Martine, il réfléchit. On na
papas la stratégie ce soir. Il y
enen a une qui est prête à
plplonger, c'est Martine Ouellet
ququi achève de nouveaux
paparticules qu'on ne voit pas
sosouvent qui s'appelle climat
QuQuébec. C'est un parti
inindépendantiste et qui fait de
lala lutte aux changements
clclimatiques en priorité.
- - Il va y avoir pas mal de
papartis indépendantistes qui vt
sese présenter là.
IlIl y a le parti pour
l'l'indépendance du Québec ossex
ququi va présenter son chef. Ils
vovont s'épeler sur le pied dans
cecette parcelle. Je peux
cocomprendre que ça va être risé
popour Paul Saint-Pierre Plamonn
dede se présenter rapidement à
cecette élection surtout que c't
lala part, il va être extrêmemet
afaffaibli pour l'élection
gégénérale et je ne pense pas qe
lele Parti québécois va avoir le
tetemps de se trouver un autre
chchef. Mais ça démontre aussi
ququ'il n'y a plus de compter sr
OKOK pour le Parti québécois et
quque la prochaine élection va
êêtre passablement difficile.
- - Madame Anglade hier disait
ququ'elle serait prête à respecr
cecette règle non écrite ou le
paparti laisse le champ libre àn
nonon chef de parti pour qu'il
pupuisse avoir sa place à
l'l'Assemblée nationale. Elle
seserait prête à ne pas présentr
dede candidats pour le Parti
lilibéral. En quelque part, elle
lele fait pour elle ou elle fait
popour faire une fleur? Qu'est-e
quque vous en pensez Martine?
- - C'est facile de faire une
ofoffre comme ça quant à zéro
chchances de gagner la
cicirconscription pointue force
leles autres à trancher et je te
memets en valeur. C'est exactemt
cece qu'elle a fait. C'est vrai
quque ça s'est fait. On l'a vu
dadans le passé. Mais dans ce c-
cici, je ne pense pas que ça vae
fafaire parce que Québec solidae
a a une chance de livrer une
babataille dans cette
cicirconscription. L'ombre
PaPandemica pour le parti
d'd'opposition a été difficile.
CeCette parcelle va leur permete
dede se mettre en valeur. Je pee
ququ'il va y avoir une course et
MaMartine Ouellet notamment tu
veveut reprendre du service. Ila
y y avoir visiblement une
cacampagne.
- - On va suivre ça, on n'a pasa
dadate encore. On comprend que e
n'n'est pas pour tout de suite.e
seserait certainement pas avant
jajanvier.
- - Pas avant les fêtes, c'est e
quque dit Monsieur Legault.
- - C'est un gros test pour Paul
SaSaint-Pierre Plamondon. Il va
avavoir beaucoup de pression por
ququ'il y aille.
- - Il reste des affaires pose a
ququestion à chaque fois qu'il e
prprésente devant un micro. Le
fafait de faire durer le suspene
cocomme ça, c'est tout pour
rerelancer et ramener le sujet r
lala table.
- - Il peut quand même dire : tt
quque l'élection n'est pas
dédéclenchée, je ne prononcerai
papas.
- - On est en attente du
dédévoilement de la stratégie. n
vava parler de l'UPAC. Monsieur
GaGaudreault reconnaît qu'il y a
unune crise de confiance envers
cecette organisation. Il dit :
lalaissez-moi trois ans, je suis
enen train de faire de l'embauc,
onon va avoir nos propres
enenquêteurs. Réaction de la
miministre de la sécurité publie
GeGeneviève Guilbault. On l'écoe
totout de suite.
GEGENEVIÈVE GUILBAULT, ministre
dede la Sécurité publique, Québc
- - Donnons-leur une chance de..
CoComment dire? De pouvoir
ututiliser de manière optimale
etet complète les outils qu'on
a a enfin mis à leur dispositio,
àà travers deux projets de loi
ququ'on a fait adopter en moins
dede trois ans. On nomme
dedes gens indépendants pour
fafaire un travail à la tête
d'd'institutions indépendantes.
CeCes gens-là, c'est leur
reresponsabilité de faire
fofonctionner les institutions.
NoNous, notre... moi,
mama responsabilité, c'est de lr
dodonner des outilils. C'est fa.
MaMaintenant, moi aussi, je suis
papas particulièrement patiente
dadans la vie. Donc, là, je pene
ququ'il va falloir un moment
dodonné aussi que ça évolue.
- - Christian, est-ce qu'on a
trtrois ans pour attendre et ler
dodonner une chance pour rebâtir
cecette confiance?
- - Pour le citoyen ordinaire et
jeje suis un citoyen ordinaire -
dededans, la réputation des l'UC
esest tellement rattachée. Ce
n'n'est pas juste le fait qu'ele
a a pas livré la marchandise, ce
ququ'elle a fait du mal. Monsier
GaGaudreault nous dit : attendez
enen 2024. Moi, je n'y crois pas
bebeaucoup à ça. Je n'ai pas de
sosolution, mais je trouve que
c'c'est une blague l'UPAC ou les
gegens sont écoeurés. Est-ce qul
fafaut l'abolir? La fusionner ac
lala Sûreté du Québec? Changer e
nonom, c'est un peu comme le
nonouveau Coke.
LeLe problème est là, mais l'UP,
ilils sont à terre. Autrement d,
popour être positif, si Monsieur
GaGaudreault était capable ici e
trtrois ans de faire un coup
d'd'éclat, quelque chose qui nos
ététonnerait tous, mais sans ça,
jeje ne vois pas comment il peut
réréussir.
- - Il dit qu'il n'est pas fermà
unun changement de nom, mais das
leles faits, changer de nom, ça
sesert à quoi?
- - Ça ne sert pas à grand-chose
sisi le produit ne s'améliore p.
MaMais d'autre part, j'ai entenu
MmMme Guilbault aujourd'hui dire
dede façon assez claire que ça e
l'l'intéressait pas. Je ne pense
papas que ce soit à court terme
unune option. Je ne pense pas nn
plplus que Mme Guilbault a envie
dede se lancer dans une
réréorganisation des sélections.
AlAlors je penense bien que Monr
GaGaudreault dispose d'au moins
l'l'élection est probablement un
anan après l'élection pour faire
seses preuves. Il ne faudrait ps
papar contre il y a a d'autres
babavures comme on n'en a vu
dedernièrement, je pense à l'ex
mamaire de Terrebonne. Ce ne
seserait plus récupérable. Au
momoment où on se parle, je pene
quque l'UPAC encore une chance,
mamais c'est la dernière.
- - Quand vous parlez des débois
dudu procès qui a complètement
dédéraillé, il y a eu arrêt des
prprocédures. La juge a eu des
momots extrêmement durs à celui
ququi est numéro deux de l'UPAC.
- - Et qui est parti.
- - La juge parle des
rereprésentations trompeuses, ds
prpropos mensongers, de
mamalhonnêteté. Quand on parle s
crcrises de confiance, voici une
jujuste qui n'a rien fait pour
aiaider. Et il y avait cet
éléléphant dans la pièce comme n
l'l'a dit pendant ce point de
prpresse Martine sur l'enquête
MMâchurer qui est en train de
babattre des records de longueur
icici. Monsieur Gaudreault contu
àà s'accrocher.
IlIl dit qu'elle continue, qu'ee
esest compliquée et que les fuis
nene les ont pas aidés. Est-ce
ququ'il y a encore quelqu'un qui
crcroit à cette enquête dans la
pipièce?
- - Il a visiblement la RAI
crcroire. J'aimerais dire une
chchose sur le procès avorté de
l'l'ancien maire de Terrebonne.l
y y a quand même de l'UPAC. L'UC
sosous Robert Lafrenière où on a
eueu les accusations de Nathalie
NoNormandeau, Guy Ouellette, des
dédéputés. Tout ça est tombé. Ce
ququi est arrivé avec l'ancien
mamaire de Terrebonne, c'est sos
FrFrédéric Gaudreault. C'est la
nonouvelle administration. La
dedernière fois qu'on a vu un
prprocès avorté parce que les
popoliciers avaient mal fait ler
trtravail, ils avaient caché ou
plplanté de la preuve, mon
sosouvenir est le procès des
frfrères dans les années 90 quia
dédéclenché sur la commission
d'd'enquête pointera sur le
trtravail des enquêteurs de la
SSûreté du Québec. Le
gogouvernement s'en est assez bn
titiré parce qu'il y avait autre
chchose dans l'actualité, mais
pepeut-être que le gouvernement
dedevraiait regarder sa d'un peu
plplus proche.
- - Vous avez vu le recul que
MoMonsieur Gaudreault a pris. Il
sesemblait même avoir une certae
coconfiance que ça pourrait
reredémarrer ce procès.
- - Je trouve que l'UPAC a
tetellement déçu. On lui a
tetellement cru à un moment doné
etet ils ont eu une marge de
mamanoeuvre énorme. On a appriss
ababus qui nous est donné beaucp
dede gens qui sont normalement
hohonnêtes et intègres. C'est pr
çaça que je trouve que l'image
n'n'est pas tout, mais en termes
dede relations publiques et
d'd'images, cette institution,
c'c'est bien beau les belles
paparoles de Monsieur Gaudreaul,
mamais il faut se souvenir de ce
quque c'était le paquet, c'était
cocomme le chevalier sans peur t
sasans reproche. Moi
pepersonnellement je n'y crois
plplus.
- - Et croyez-vous à l'enquête
MMâchurer?
- - C'est tellement compliqué.
- - Mâchurer, ça commence à êtr.
ilil a même dit lui-même, il a t
: : tous les éléments d'enquête
onont chuté dans les médias. Les
pepersonnes qui sont sous enquê,
çaça fait plus de sept ans qu'iy
a a une enquête criminelle au-
dedessus de leur tête et ça inct
lele premier ministre Jean
ChCharest.
- Michel sur Mâchurer?
- - Ça ne peut pas durer
ététernellement. Il y a peut-ête
unun fondement au soupçon que
l'l'UPAC peut entretenir. Mais
enencore faut il arrivait à une
dédémonstration qui ferait... qi
titiendrait la route devant les
trtribunaux. S'il n'y arrive pa,
onon ne peut pas continuer encoe
cocomme ça pendant des années. e
pepense que d'ici un an, si on t
papas... on n'a pas réussi à
prprésenter quelque chose de
sosolide, il va falloir
ababandonner.
- - Il faut arrêter le supplice.
AiAir Canada soudainement,
mimiracle, le chef de la directn
MiMichael Rousseau à trouver une
plplace dans son agenda poursuie
dedes cours personnels intenses
dedes Français.
MiMichel, est-ce que tout ça en
bobout de ligne va avoir eu du
bobon? Parce que ça a dévoilé un
prproblème à la haute directione
PaParcs Canada et le message que
çaça renvoie aux troupes, à tous
leles employés.
- - On va le voir assez
rarapidement. Dans le cas de
MoMonsieur Rousseau, j'imagine
ququ'il va essayer dans son
prprochain discours de nous
imimpressionner avec son frança.
AuAu-delà de ça, c'est le
fofonctionnement d'Air Canada qi
esest un problème récurrent deps
sasa création. D'une fois à
l'l'autre, ça ne s'améliore pas.
C'C'est le champion toutes
cacatégories des plaintes au
cocommissaire officiel. On va vr
susur le terrain. Chacun a sa
pepetite histoire à raconter sur
l'l'unilinguisme chez Air Canad.
VoVous et moi et tous les
frfrancophones qui vont prendre
l'l'avion vont pouvoir juger.
- - Christian là-dessus, vous az
écécrit une chronique dans la
prpresse. C'est un sujet qui vit
vrvraiment vous chercher?
- - C'est mignon de voir Monsier
RoRousseau suivre des cours de
frfrançais pour l'image, mais on
vava voir s'il est capable de
paparler français. Il n'a pas ue
obobligation de moyens, il a une
obobligation de résultat. Je
trtrouve que c'est beaucoup plus
largrge qu'Air Canada.
CoComme l'avait écrit Stéphanie
GrGrammond dans la presse, qui
ététait plus choquant que le
didiscours en anglais seulement,
c'c'est le fait que les 320
pepersonnes de la chambre de
cocommerce du Montréal
mémétropolitain ont applaudi
ununanimement. Il n'y en a pas n
ququi a réagi. Ça a fait ressorr
quque le problème vient en parte
dedes francophones qui peuvent
êêtre serviles, assimilée. C'est
bebeaucoup plus lalarge que ça.
C'C'est une bonne nouvelle, il
nonous fait un cadeau Monsieur
RoRousseau parce qu'il révèle
ququelque chose qui existe de
PaParcs Canada n'ont pas le cho.
C'C'est un manque de jugement de
lala Air Canada. Et la France qi
a a également pathologique, mais
onon va bien le public. ; ; Il,l
apapprend pas autre chose. Ce
n'n'est pas de.
- - Il y a une utile de mettre n
plplace,, de l'entreprise, ça
m'm'amène à avant de être
ilils ont des comptes à rendre x
cicitoyens. On va voir si Monsir
RoRousseau va le faire.
- - Ils ont répondu tellement ve
àà la lettre de Mme Freeland
ququ'on a l'impression que la
lelettre de riposte était déjà
écécrite pratiquement.
- - Je trouve que ça attire
l'l'attention sur le fait que la
dédéfense du français, ce n'est
papas juste Simon Jolin-Barrett,
cece sont toutes les francophons
enen position d'autorité qui dot
sese tenir debout davantage pare
quque Monsieur Michel Rousseau,e
n'n'est pas possible qu'on vous
rereçoive...
- - on a plus de temps, mais ona
trtrès